okay earlier in the program I alluded to
robert muller the special prosecutor
seemingly focusing on possible financial
crimes hiring experts in international
money laundering etc in his
investigation of the Trump Russia
scandal and that would explain a lot
about Donald Trump's reluctant to
release his tax returns if that is the
area where Trump is most liable or at
risk then it would make sense that he
would not want his tax returns being
public the details of a particular
Donald Trump real estate deal have now
gone public and they look a whole hell
of a lot like criminal tax fraud we
don't have his tax returns but we do
have the documents for one particular
transaction and it relates to a
pre-election
sale of property from a company
controlled by Donald Trump to a company
controlled by his son Eric Trump okay so
here's the way it went
April of 2016 there's a company managed
by Donald Trump which sold two condos to
a company managed by Eric Trump each
condo sold for three hundred and fifty
thousand dollars now so far you might
hear that if you live in many parts of
the United States and say okay what why
is that even remotely alarming the
medium home prep median home price in
the United States a couple of years ago
was around two hundred thousand dollars
three hundred and fifty thousand dollar
condos slightly more expensive than the
average property no big deal
the problem is this was New York City
not only that it was Manhattan not only
that it was Central Park Avenue South
not only that it was a full-service
doorman building on the 13th and 14th
floors of an apartment on Central Park
Avenue South sounds like it will be a
little bit more expensive than $350,000
is not a price that makes sense
the condos there sell for a lot more in
fact two years before Trump sold these
two condos to his son a similar
apartment 5g Trump's apartments were 13
and 14 G usually the same letter is the
same floor plan right these are verdict
apartments vertically stacked above each
other
sold for nearly seven hundred thousand
dollars two months before this sale to
Eric trump the same units were
advertised for around eight hundred
thousand dollars each so there's this
little thing called the law very
important thing people tell me but they
don't always know because my dad was in
real estate
he was small loan of a million dollars
because I make great deals there's this
thing called the law where if a parent
and child do a real estate sale for fair
market value you don't pay any gift tax
if a parent sells their kid real estate
at a discounted price then that is a
partially taxable gift the seller must
pay a gift tax of up to 40% in this case
that gift tax would have run Trump about
three hundred and fifty thousand dollars
each taxpayer gets a five point forty
nine million dollar lifetime exemption
meaning you can give away that much
money without incurring the tax and to
claim that a transaction is covered by
that exemption you have to file a gift
tax return so of course we don't have
Trump's tax returns but we do have the
New York City property tax records great
and those show that Trump paid $13,000
in state and local transfer taxes for
two sales that happens to be the amount
that would be paid when you have a real
estate sale between two strangers but if
he paid state and local transfer taxes
that means these transfers of real
estate were not treated as gifts and on
the real estate tax forms that were
filed in New York Trump didn't check any
of the boxes indicating that these were
sales between relatives or of less than
the entire property value these
transactions were treated as if they
were fair market sales to a stranger
meaning it's almost certain that Trump
didn't file a federal gift tax return
and willful failure to file such a tax
return is a misdemeanor and there is
also a possible evasion of taxes charged
here which is a felony you know these
charges do seem pretty damaging but of
course Trump can just exonerate himself
if he decides to release his tax returns
you know of course for joking but this
guy's been doing shady business deals
for years and I don't think the public
would have known about it had he decided
not to run for president that's why I
connected to running mobsters and all
this crazy stuff that's why I keep
saying this has got to be the worst
possible thing for Trump's business and
and his personal finances having having
run for president and I know he's
already making money off of the
presidency filtering money through
Secret Service into his hotels and all
sorts of other stuff but the scrutiny
that he's under and it really is damning
in terms of our system that the Trump's
are so brazen in these types of actions
and they face zero consequences and this
is where you hear this fallacious
argument that liberals hate the rich
liberals don't hate the rich they hate
that there's a different standard when
it comes to criminality for the rich and
for other people and for what
individuals who are really wealthy are
able to get away with that's the problem
that liberals have it's not hating the
rich and now it's even legally ambiguous
as to if Donald Trump can be prosecuted
for any of the criminally yeah obviously
this that wouldn't happen to begin with
I guess he could have a civil case
against him because the president was
set back with the Paula Jones scandal
and Bill Clinton but of course the tax
evasion base any charges for this tax
evasion would be criminal and of course
it doesn't appear as though a sitting
president can be charged criminally the
video you just finished watching was
made possible by you through the
membership program you can sign up for
membership at david pakman.com slash
membership we are viewer supported
independent media you can use the coupon
code
I voted 17 for a 40% discount off of
your membership